it started as a legend one of the  greatest of all thousand years who've  kept it hidden to protect Earth what was  destined to arrive Optimus Prime you  destroyed your home you credential I do  [Music]  your daughter what would you say to her  first your teeth work hard stay with  money boy in a band especially a drummer  these are troubled times without leaders  chaos reigns  two worlds collide  you're all that stand in its way now the  greatest mission of them all to turn the  tide of human history  Frank bill can't do  [Applause]  the imminent destruction of everything  we know and love begins  [Music]  not leaving you  my no screams lost a few brave souls  [Music]  everything who doesn't know the  operation is over  we're not give it up a prime okay  on this case  and I once like this  [Music]  for my world to live  yours must die  [Music]  you